it's not even just about money
um that's why I
deliberately don't check views and likes
and all that kind of stuff is you don't
want that dopamine of like
um of pulling you in I have to do the
thing that gets more and more attention
or
um more and more like yeah like money
and yeah it's a huge negative hit on
your um
and you're your ability to do creative
work can can I ask you about that
because I always I'm always interested
in this
um I completely agree I think it's funny
because when you abstract yourself out
to the people you admire and respect who
inspired you to do the Creative work you
do
you never think about like the views
they were getting or the money they were
making or the influence they had all you
ever think about is the work itself
and it's funny when a lot of people get
in this position
your temptation is to focus on that
which you can measure which is like all
the stuff you said like the likes the
view that's not actually the Target or
what you got into it for if you get into
it for like because you're inspired or
whatever your goal is inspiration it's
impact and like that can't be Quantified
that same way
so it's interesting you have to find a
way as a creator of any of this stuff to
like deliberately detach yourself from
the measurable and focus on this thing
which is kind of abstract and I was
wondering if you have any like ideas for
that so one yeah there's a bunch of
ideas so one is
uh
uh figure out ways Where You Don't See
the number of views on things so I have
I wrote a Chrome extension for myself
that hides the number of views
um that's really funny yeah I know
what's funny because it's useful for
other people's right oh my God
I'm gonna need to borrow this that was
my problem I actually have some Chrome
extensions for like I don't like going
down like recommendation rabbit holes
when I'm at work I just want to like
search for a video find it I don't want
to see like all the up next because I'll
waste time so I use Chrome extensions
for that but the views is a problem
because it's relevant to me as a Creator
like is this a big video is it us yeah
which is why I really hurt when they
remove like likes and dislikes because I
want to know tutorials and so on uh
what's I mean that's probably really
useful for you that dislikes yeah yeah
do you have that do you ever ever
considered making that Chrome extension
public sure it actually yeah and there
would be a good philosophy behind it
right like don't if you're a Creator I
love the idea I've wanted this thing
before I don't know if it necessarily
exists because I don't think I've made a
a Chrome extension public that'd be cool
I would love to see yeah I would go to
that process of adding it to the because
I love like open sourcing stuff so yeah
I'll go add it to the Chrome extension
like the the store yeah because I I
totally have I've hated this for like a
long time YouTube made a change and they
just continue to make the analytics
front and center which makes sense from
their perspective they're trying to give
people better data on what is successful
and what makes something successful
they're trying to train their creators
but in the process it can lead to some
unhealthy habits of thinking views to
find a video and so I've long thought
okay I've learned analytics I understand
retention now I sort of want to do like
the Zen like forget it all though and
you can only do that if it's out of your
site depends how many friends you have
who are creatives the other really
important thing and I found this this
has nothing to do with creatives but uh
people are respect very much in my life
some of them people would know that they
could be famous
they will come to me and say they will
comment on how popular a video was on
YouTube
they will sort of complement
the success the the success defined by
the popularity even for a podcast where
most of the the listenership is not on
YouTube or in Spotify now is getting
crazy the they will still complement the
YouTube number so one of the deliberate
things I do is I either depending if
it's a close friend I'll get offended
and made fun of them for that and
there's sort of signal to them this is
not the right thing yeah I don't want
that and uh for people more like
strangers that complement that kind of
stuff I shown zero interest I don't
receive the compliment well and I focus
on the aspects of the compliment that
have to do with like what what do they
find interesting like you know I kind of
make them reveal to them that you
shouldn't care about the number the
number of views it is strange there's
like this weird hypnotism that happens
once you get past a certain number
and that number is some approximation
it's like it's always like hard numbers
it's like 100 000 a million 10 million
people just see a number and they just
go like wow that is and they assign a
quality to it that may not like it
usually means nothing at all